welcome to this video playing
adaro Gambia no I'm not believing that
okay they don't have any GMS okay but
this is going to be a nimzo I
guess 2,500 this is a pretty high
rating yeah E4 is the critical move but
this is a tricky move here with C5 as
far as I know
but D D5 Queen E7 is the problem what if
I
play what if I play something like that
let's just freestyle this and hope I'm
not falling on my face too
badly Bishop B7 Bishop D3 I think they
have ideas with B5 in this
position ah yeah I see and F3 you're
kind of telling me that the queen is bad
on
C2 that's certainly true
D5 W that looks that looks tricky very
tricky okay maybe D5 Queen
E7 and then yeah yeah yeah I have to
block it block the eal maybe with
this Ed Ed Queen E4 interesting very
interesting oh he's not doing that
okay okay I'm just going to develop if
black is just uh playing passive moves
now I'm definitely
okay now he's going Queen E4 I thought
it was Stronger
before now I can actually move the queen
away if I'm not totally wrong
here maybe here I don't know where I
mean I can Castle next
move and if he would have done that
without out playing
um other move
first strange really strange
stuff okay um I'd like to get in Bishop
D3 here
definitely Rook D1 Bishop D3
or yeah all this and Bishop E3
first then Rook D1 Bishop
D3
ah
[Music]
okay
so Rook B5 Bishop A6 and then then he
wants to take on C4
yes oh
W I really don't believe this one bit
but maybe maybe I'm wrong
so I'm taking this and then what exactly
Bishop A6 Knight
D5 I also have Bishop F4 I
mean F4 is probably also not
bad I don't know I'm falling really too
far behind on the
clock I have I have some unprotected
pieces so it's not
clear if he has some some some weird
tactic maybe to justify
stuff okay so attacking on
C3
maybe Queen F6 yeah yeah yeah it's it's
all it's always a bit tricky even if
this um it's not working objectively
it's always some activity going
on and I really only have this this
double Pawn that is my extra Pawn it's
nothing nothing too scary for
[Music]
black
um I wasn't sure if this is actually
working due to Knight
E4
94 let's
see
H I don't
know yeah he's got Rook e one yeah this
this kind of this kind of funny
idea it's unbelievable sometimes what
kind of stuff is
happening what about Bishop F1
though isn't this winning something he
has Bishop F1 yeah threatening
threatening Ma on G2 yeah he didn't he
didn't see that
check uh oh it's winning I it's winning
an exchange okay I'm sorry I didn't this
was also good
okay
um white
resigns yeah it was just just just a
weird position just a weird
position I mean okay this is probably
not working at all yeah it's not working
of course I can just take and win this
is winning and he just he's just down
material for
nothing okay and this is not working due
to this miracle Rook E4 yeah and and
this
great sometimes you're just unlucky I
mean or unlucky it's of course a skill
problem if I'm better I'm not allowing
this stuff but I mean this is just
frankly he does this in two seconds and
blunders away the whole game and it's
pretty clear that all this what he's
doing is a sort of shaky stuff yeah if
he's he's not having any tactic he's
just a pawn down and I mean this is
simply not working yeah I can just do
this and he resigns the game you can
also not do this due
to the same
thing and then I'm going Knight E4
immediately and then this is just just a
miracle save yeah yeah this is check
check this is the
problem and here again it's a it's a I
mean he could have done that as well
then I have this one though okay yeah so
he can do exactly that that F1 and this
gives him the extra
piece so yeah okay it was it was
stupid and this B5 stuff I mean I really
I really don't know if this is possible
here black is um black is probably okay
here right B5 interesting yeah it is
interesting it costs me quite um quite a
lot of time it's got this counter play
against the Pawns
and as mentioned it's just a double Pawn
so it's not like I just have a pawn and
I win
easily but um yeah okay he's got a weak
Pawn on D6 and so on I should never be
worse and here yeah he has to play
something else I mean just just blunders
it
away something I don't know Rook E7 or
whatever move when I can try to convert
the pawn the problem is that it's not
the pawn the problem is that D6 is weak
and this these pieces are we they're
attacking this Pawn but other than that
they're just not very well placed so
here he has to um be yeah it's a tough
defense for him and well this this
should have lost but uh it won because I
I did a really stupid I played Knight E4
I took some time for it right 11 seconds
yeah but I I was just not seeing that
it's always a check that here's Rook e
one
and Rook F1 this this kind of
thing okay thanks for watching